adidas and puma are two of the biggest
rivals in shoes
but did you know that their founders
were two halves of a once happy family
business
that turned into a level of brother rage
so intense
it will get the sneaker heads tongues a
wagon see what i did there
in the 1930s the dassler brothers sports
shoe company in bavaria
made the most kick-ass athletic shoes in
all the land
the company even gave jesse owens a pair
of shoes to compete in the 36 olympics
when jesse won the brothers shoes blew
up
but all of that success was not good for
their relationship
tensions flared some say there was
stealing affairs
resentment and after world war ii
the brothers were so out of step they
eventually ended the company
in 1949 adolf or addy dassler
formed adidas a play on his nickname
rudolph dazzler
started puma because well that name is
awesome
the brothers sued each other many many
times over the years
over all sorts of design and trademark
issues
costing each other a fortune in lawyers
and suits there are two factories built
in the same bavarian village of
hetengenaro
polarized the community with local
people picking signs by picking shoes
the brothers died two years apart they
are buried at opposite ends
of the village graveyard proof that even
in death there remained
a great bitter divide between them and
so it was for decades
until 2009 employees of adidas and puma
in the village where the two companies
still have their headquarters came
together
and played a friendly soccer match and
started the process of healing decades
of enmity
and began a new era of love and shoes
[Music]
you